mommy stopped eating it oh my god this
is so good my name is Katie and I'm here
with my beautiful mom Carol I know we're
gonna teach you how to make Trinidadian
roti or we like to call bus up shot and
read different fillings roti
it's a flatbread well bus up shop
basically is an Indian type of roti that
they break apart and it's very much
eaten by hands we need everything by
hands you can see some other deviation
to it because it's all about texture do
you want it softer you wanted a little
crunchy you know it depends on what
you're looking to do for the Caribbean
people they love a soft
melt-in-your-mouth kind of roti
some people put milk a little oil which
I do sometimes we're gonna do the
traditional so it's a traditional
technique where when it's time to
actually roll the roti we'll have a
layer of butter in the center how good
roti has good bread you will fail if
your roti isn't moist this is called
sawfish bull joy which is a Caribbean
food that we create out of dry codfish
and lots of vegetables in the Caribbean
you know it's very hot so a lot of our
foods are either highly seasoned and
spiced or the fish itself it's cured so
that they can last we just clean it
debone it boil it and wash it several
times so we're going to put in the
sawfish which we washed and coats and
cleans I'm super obsessed with this
whole fish so I had to learn how to make
it immediately because it was like
something I tried to eat for breakfast
lunch and dinner which I don't advise
there's something called the green
seasoning they could remain people used
to marinate the food it's a process that
we use to make sure that the meat stay
fresh when you blend it it goes right
into the chicken but then you use less
because you're using it more
concentrated I like the chunks because
when you're eating you're getting the
veggies everything is going to disappear
anyways we're making curry coconut
chicken coconut trees are all over
Trinidad so we've made coconut oil to
our here and our
we have always drank the coconut water
so you'll find it in the food if you are
making a dish from a specific region
when it comes to certain by let's try to
get it from that region you want to get
a Caribbean curry opposed to a Madras
curry this way it stays in line with the
flavor you're trying to create I find
that when I am preparing food it takes
me back to connecting with my mother I
could feel the connection with my
parents I think all Caribbean people
know how to cook it's just something
they do because there's no one to do it
for you and it's the way you just
entertain it's always over food if you
have children there's always that one
house that all the kids would go to and
that's usually the one with the mom that
takes care of all of the kids so I'll
feed them it was eight of us the girls
always had to learn to cook very
chauvinistic I didn't know we were doing
sustainable living I just know we had
our own chickens we had a lot of
property so we ate everything that we
raised all group I've actually never
helped my mom make roti I've helped her
make bake another kinds of bread if I'm
even on a diet I will stop because roti
and Bing are like my favorite breads of
all time Caribbean people are very
traditional I mean they may look at my
video and say oh no that's wrong it's a
lot of little tricks and however you
like your food you should be able to
make it the end of the day it still has
to taste good
hmm I think that's perfect